while humans tend to think of themselves
as the smartest creatures on earth the
animals in this video prove that
sometimes we need a little help from the
other members of the food chain from
man's best friend to the king of the
jungle prepare to be blown away by some
unbelievable animals that saved people's
lives Khan to the rescue an average day
in the backyard nearly turned into a
nightmare for this Australian family
only days after being introduced to his
new home Khan a Doberman Pinscher
managed to save the life of 17 month-old
Charlotte the two were playing in the
backyard when the pooch noticed a king
brown snake one of the world's deadliest
hiding underneath the house sensing the
danger of the dog quickly grabbed the
child by the diaper and tossed it to
safety for his heroic actions Khan
received a bite on the paw luckily for
him Charlotte's mother witnessed the
entire incident and managed to rush the
unlikely hero to the hospital in the
nick of time dory the rabbit not many
people can claim to have had their life
saved by a rabbit however this
Englishman has probably told his story
enough time to make up for it Simon's
the gal a lifelong diabetic fell into a
coma while watching television within
moments his pet rabbit Dory was jumping
up and down on his chest in an attempt
to wake them up the animals peculiar
behavior was enough to draw the
attention of stegall's wife who quickly
called the paramedics
porpoises faced a familiar face film and
television actor Dick Van Dyke revealed
on the Craig Ferguson show that in his
younger years a group of porpoises and
managed to save his life in an unlikely
way while lounging on a surfboard van
Dijk dozed off only to wake up so far
out he could no longer see the shore as
he began to paddle with the swells he
noticed a number of fins coming closer
and closer thankfully for him and all
the fans the fans turned out to be
attached to a group of helpful porpoises
which pushed the actor to safety Jane
teased a gorilla a fun day at the zoo
nearly turned deadly after a
three-year-old boy fell 18 feet into a
gorilla pit while visiting with his
family as the boy's mother rushed to the
scene she noticed that some of the
gorillas were beginning to take an
interest in their new Penn mate that's
when something shocking occurred binti a
7 year old female picked the boy up and
carried him to the other side of the
pick
review officials would have a better
chance of retrieving him a miraculous
feat for any animal think he's actions
more than likely save the boy's life
from some of the more aggressive
gorillas saved by lions while they have
been defined more often than not for
their ability to tear through flesh this
particular pack of lines decided to
abstain from their usual habits to save
the life of a 12 year old Ethiopian girl
after being kidnapped by four men on her
way home from school
the girl was saved when three lines
chased away her abductors and stood
guard until the police arrived one
expert believes the pride may have
mistaken the cries of the young girl for
those of a lion cub thus explaining why
they spared her life
either way the police may want to
consider hiring the furry beasts as
consultants carry the horse it was just
another day for Farmer Fiona Boyd when
she had to rely on the wits of her horse
to survive a dangerous situation
Fiona was attempting to move a cow and
its calf from one spot to another when
the mother began to attack her lying on
the ground and fearing for her life
Fiona was saved by her horse Kerrygold
the creature had been observing the
situation and rushed to the aid of her
owner kicking away the cow Carrie did
enough to allow her owner to escape in
the nick of time kilo the pitbull when a
man posing as a FedEx driver attempted
to push his way into their Staten Island
home Justin Becker and his dog kilo
sprang into action as becquer slam the
intruder against the door hila lunged at
him fighting ferociously in a state of
panic the man shot the heroic pitbull
before running away after rushing into
the hospital it was determined that the
wound wasn't serious
allowing tiro to return home a hero
dolphin he rose while swimming in the
ocean with his daughter and two of her
friends Rob House noticed something
peculiar a group of dolphins have begun
to surround them initially confused
house quickly realized the dolphins were
attempting to hurt him and his
companions away from a 10-foot great
white shark swimming nearby the Dolphins
continue to protect the group for 40
minutes only dispersing after the
enormous predator began to retreat the
ability of the fin creatures to sense
danger allowed this group of swimmers to
escape unharmed we need a cat Smith's
out danger after being woken up in the
middle
by her cat Winnie Kathy Kaitlyn quickly
sent stuff something was wrong a water
pump had broken while she and the rest
of her family were sleeping
causing poisonous carbon monoxide to
fill their home her husband and son
unconscious Kathy immediately called 911
luckily for the Keith Lang's their cat
when he noticed the change in the air
and didn't waste any time alerting them
to the danger Mandy the goat one 78 year
old farmer Noel Osbourne fell into a
pile of manure it was anything but funny
the fall broke his hip rendering him
completely immobile for the next five
days Noel was kept alive by his goat
Mandy she would allow him to drink her
milk and would lie beside him at night
to keep him warm while Noel would make a
full recovery after being rescued by
friends he owes a debt of gratitude to
Mandy and her heroic actions have you
ever been saved by an animal tell us
about it in the comment section and
don't forget to subscribe to the thing